voilà après on va juger aussi en
fonction de votre niveau vous proposer
comment cibler les bonnes offres sur
internet comment mettre en valeur ses
compétences derrière un écran voilà
quelques-unes des problématiques qui se
posent aux demandeurs d'emploi elles
sont aujourd'hui surmonté grâce à ce
forum et pour mélissa qui recherchent un
cdi depuis un an et demi le premier
entretien de la journée semble déjà être
le bon je cherche vraiment à pouvoir
m'épanouir dans un travail qui me plaît
ce que je faisais de la que je fais de
l'accueil depuis un an et demi c'est ce
qui me plaît réellement
on m'a demandé ce que j'avais fait quel
était mon parcours et ça s'est super
bien passé parce qu'on m'appelle demain
pour un entretien
comme mélissa à près de 500 personnes se
sont rendues au forum organisé par l'
agence pôle emploi de guyancourt
l'occasion pour les candidats d'approché
directement des potentiels employeurs
c'est vrai que nous dans notre quotidien
quand je rencontre les employeurs quand
une sollicite pour diffuser des entend
pas à leur trouver des profils là où on
a le plus de retour à l'emploi c'est
quand on organise les rencontres donc
que ce soit sous forme de job dating ou
sous ce système de forums côté employeur
une vingtaine d'entreprises et de
centres de formation étaient présents
des buts c'est d'être vraiment
confrontés directement au public
demandeurs d'emploi parce que c'est vrai
qu'un cv c'est pas très parlant
là on a l'occasion au moins de pouvoir
les voir en direct de discuter avec eux
leur donner des conseils aussi parce que
parfois ils ne savent pas vraiment
rédiger correctement un cv donc on a des
bonnes surprises donc on est là vraiment
pourront rencontrer des candidats prend
des rendez vous avec ceux qui
correspondent en tout cas nos pré requis
de recrutement au total près de 120
postes étaient à pourvoir lors de cette
journée un espace dédié à la préparation
de l'entretien d'embauché était
également mise en place